what we're replacing is five hours in
the makeup chair I have a rubber glute
all over your face Avatar
avatoning today
it's all thanks to everyone's
willingness to look absolutely
ridiculous on set number one let's take
a dip in the water for a second for the
Avatar sequel Kate Winslet had to learn
to hold her breath underwater while we
thought it was impossible to hold your
breath for more than a couple of minutes
we can guarantee that her record took
our breath away she got up to a whopping
7 minutes and 14 seconds I know I'm very
proud of that actually they couldn't use
scuba gear underwater so it was just
easier for her to learn to completely
obliterate her lungs we guess it's not
something I could just jump in the bath
and do right now number two so help us
there better be lots of banshees and
Avatar too they were the coolest part of
the original sadly they weren't exactly
cool without all the CGI and special
effects honestly whatever it is Sam
Worthington is riding on it's not an
alien bird it looks more like a baby toy
or maybe a knockoff mechanical Bowl
James Cameron's biggest Quest question
when it came to the ban she was what is
the metaphor we're trying to get across
people have asked me what was your
inspiration what was the trigger they're
looking for some kind of proximal cause
he wanted the Banshee to be Birds of
Prey Eagles alien Eagles number three
water unnecessary life force and also a
huge pain the tracking dot technology
sure has come a long way since the first
avatar however they did run into a
problem with the tech when they found
themselves in a new environment the CGI
tracking dots would reflect off of the
water this was one of the many
challenges the new environment had on
technology that was no big deal in the
jungle number four the stunt actors
would have had their work cut out for
them the nice thing about hiring stunt
actors for a CGI film is you don't need
to worry about matching doubles so much
look at the special skills these actors
had at their disposal Vine swinging come
on what Reuben Langdon hits the ground
harder than anybody I know and for the
sequel Sigourney Weaver revealed that
all of the actors had to learn parkour
number five they couldn't just find some
basketball players to play the navi
notice that the humans aren't present in
the filming of this Scene It makes
perfect sense you can't have giant
actors and Tiny actors at the same time
you'd have to film them separately and
then splice them together one way to
nail the scene was with pool noodles
okay it's probably not pool noodles but
it looks like cool noodles whatever
floats your goat right number six we bet
this jungle beast is just a putty tat on
the inside it's all about the muscles
when creating the life-like otherworldly
CGI creatures like the thanator you've
got to work from the inside out if you
miss a layer it can be spotted in your
work they built the skeleton for the
thanator and attached muscles to it over
top a black armored six-legged Panther
from hell
this is the description the alien jungle
cat had 10 years before its design came
to be it didn't change much from James
Cameron's original Vision number seven
good things come in six a similar
process to what they went through with
the thanatore they also did with the
dire horses they had to completely
re-engineer a horse's anatomy in order
to make the hexapedal design work to
capture that much Nuance in the
performance of the animal can come from
only one place studying the real thing
yes that's right they actually brought
in real horses for the actors to ride
number eight we take these
groundbreaking Technologies for granted
these days the look of the navi was not
impressing people enough so they went to
WETA to build a new face and muscle skin
system because characters are mostly
naked they have their work cut out for
them to make sure it actually looks
authentic you can't hide behind cloth
it's got more personality it's got my
soul to make the skin look real
animators had to work inside out
creating bone structures and muscles
number nine honestly we wouldn't mind a
nice cryo sleep right now the cryo
Chambers are probably the closest thing
to a set avatar ever got aside from A
Touch of Green Screen it's all real
anything that can look technical in
sci-fi was probably done more practical
than the alien counterparts anything
like the beautiful Pandora backdrops or
nature most likely are nearly entirely
if not entirely CGI a range of different
Vehicles was used for aircrafts we say
Vehicles lightly by the way they were
metal shells with different capabilities
some were strapped to wire and carried
around and some were just big metal
cages number 10. Avatar really set the
bar for intricate lighting spherical
harmonics is a data representation of
how light interacts with surfaces this
technology was first developed for the
first Avatar movie and one WETA an award
it's necessary for creating realistic
hair and eyes number 11. this is the
strangest Stampede we've ever seen it's
in incredible the depth these actors are
able to bring without having much to
work with even trees are just metal
racks and creatures a human Stampede
with baseballs on metal rods it was
heard you number 12 usually imagination
is left up to Stage or voice actors but
not for Avatar they created a teeny tiny
obstacle course for Sam Worthington to
run through and honestly we're shook so
much of the world was shot in this
high-tech cold environment we're not
sure whether to be disappointed or
impressed although film has shifted away
from digital effects recently as
audiences favor the Practical these days
but we bet the pendulum will swing back
after Avatar 2. number 13. the doctor
has arrived the navi hand is just a blue
glove it looks like a surgical glove
less than two dozen people were suited
up here despite there being hundreds of
other Navi added later we can only
wonder how they were included number 14
actors can do a lot but not everything
they're swapped out for their stunt
doubles for a moment see it the moment
natiri throws sute off Jake is this true
number 15. none of the stunts were CGI
folks okay they were CGI but that
doesn't mean the actors and stunt people
didn't still have to follow through with
them honestly we're quite impressed with
this it's really gonna hurt in the
morning number 16. Jake and the giant
beanstalk of all the things that were
more on the Practical side this was not
one of the ones we would have expected
to be built and yes they did call it the
Beanstalk number 17 all of the clothing
was hand stitched and yet got no Awards
moat's ceremonial gown was made in
multiple different Fabrics until they
managed to get exactly the right weight
that would move the way they wanted it
to move sutay's battle fringes were made
up of different weights and fabrics they
did wind tunnel tests on fabric and then
after that it was weta's job to figure
out how to incorporate that into the
animation number 18. realize Realize
Real Lies and of course the thing we
were afraid of is what people have
sometimes called the Dead Eye effect
mounting cameras directly to actors
heads is how they solved this issue with
a tight fitting carbon fiber helmet that
was molded to their heads to capture
every minute detail number 19 Avatar is
the reason single camera TV shows exist
they were using them all we said well we
have a fully virtual world let's shoot
it in a fully virtual way they had two
completely different camera systems
taking it from a point where you had to
wait months to see something where he's
getting in real time one was a virtual
camera system to capture actors in a
virtual environment Jim can frame his
virtual camera up and see his character
there on the Fly the other was to shoot
live-action actors and sets in 3D
there's nowhere to hide through every
day you have to be truthful number 20
they went into the forest half naked for
research taking the actors into nature
really informed their performance Upon
returning to the mocap filming space the
actors found they retained the
experience the memories of the little
things like how it feels for your foot
to step in mud James Cameron found
inspiration for many visuals by sending
the actors out there too but I think the
biggest part of it that was valuable was
just the kind of kinesthetic sense
memory number 21 on top of fight
training learning a new language etc etc
the actors also needed to learn
choreography all of the movement was
specially choreographed but sadly many
dance numbers were actually cut out of
the film without the choreographer the
navi would have been missing an integral
part of their characteristics as a
community number 22 James Cameron grew
tired waiting for the tech to catch up
so the Avatar crew invented it
themselves Jim wrote Avatar way back in
1994. it was meant to be made right
after Titanic but the technology just
wasn't there yet so the script got put
off until it could catch up in order to
honor Jim's Vision they got caught up in
2005 when they asked Fox for the time
and money to research the tech
technology could we really do the things
we think we can do number 23 before
Avatar there was Avatar before they ever
had their actors cast They cast two
temporary actors to create a 37 second
clip YC yes why save just creating this
prototype would have cost a fortune
number 24. cats were a huge part of the
navi design I feel like I'm blue and I'm
nine feet tall and I'm as sexy as hell
arriving at the design of the navi was
no easy task Jim always knew he wanted
them to be blue but the animal features
like the cat ears tail and nose as well
as lemur-like eyes came organically
along the way at first they were
designed to look amphibious and then
more alien with antennae and such they
kept coming back to blue skinned humans
and that wasn't working either but the
big problem was Jim didn't feel he could
tell a love story if the characters
weren't beautiful I wanted people to say
I want to be one of them they put the
actors in these sphere shapes and
photographed them from every angle with
different lighting patterns to study the
actors facial features and design
characters based on that number 25 do
you think they let the actor see what
was up on screen to give them a sense of
the magic the stunning bioluminescent
tree is nothing more than a few threads
on a metal pole but you probably figured
that out by now but what they could see
behind their specialized camera was
already nearly good enough for a video
game maybe not for theaters but for a
video game while the Wood Sprite was
puppeted on a stick so Avatar is making
its triumphant return to theaters did
you bear witness to history being made
the first time let us know in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things